-My first guest is an
Emmy and Golden Globe winner
and one of the
funniest people on the planet.
The first two seasons of
his acclaimed series,
"After Life," --
Gosh, it's a good show.
It's such a good mix of
comedy and drama.
He's awesome.
They're available right now
on Netflix.
Here's the one-and-only
Ricky Gervais!
Hey! There he is.
That's what I'm talking about.
Ricky Gervais, look at you, man.
You look fantastic.
Wow! Thank you so much
for doing this.
I appreciate this.
I know you're in --
You're over in U.K. right now,
so thank you for doing this.
Last time we talked
was in April.
We were on Zoom right --
maybe like a month
into quarantine.
And so thanks
for doing that, by the way.
-I haven't moved.
I've been in this --
And nothing's happened.
"Groundhog Day."
I've been here.
In fact, you might have well
rerun the interview from April.
Nothing's happened.
-Nothing has changed?
Nothing happened?
-Nothing changed.
I'm probably wearing
the same T-shirt.
-Could we do that?
We'll just run
the other interview.
Yeah, we might as well
just do it.
-No one would know.
-Well, look,
the good news is that
the vaccines
are being rolled out.
-Yeah.
-And they're -- I mean,
you're on the list, obviously.
-I'm on the list,
but we checked, right?
I wasn't even registered
to a doctor.
I had to go online
to register --
I don't go to the doctor.
And I got registered.
And you put in your details,
and it tells you where you are.
And there's like 30 million
people ahead of me.
How can I not be vulnerable?
Look at me.
How can there people --
I mean, it's so annoying.
I can't wait to get --
I will fight an old lady
for that vaccine.
It will be like
"Game of Thrones."
I will grab that.
-No.
-I'll be like a deranged junkie.
I will grab the needle
out of her arm.
Of course I will.
-That's not true at all.
-Do you know what, though?
Ah! See?
My plan is -- alright? --
within the next few months,
I'm going to be clinically obese
so I'll be high risk.
I'll walk in and I'll go --
I'll sit down.
I'll go, "Hello, Doctor."
[ Wheezes ]
And I'll be breathing heavily.
And they'll go,
"Jesus, let's get this fat
[bleep] injected.
He's going to die," right?
And then --
-This is a bad plan.
No. This is a very bad plan.
Do not do that. Oh, just don't.
But, eventually,
we'll all get it,
and then we'll talk
and we'll be happy to have you.
Oh, you know what
I want to ask you about?
I heard that there's
a new addition to the family,
because I know
you're a huge animal lover.
And, like a lot of people
who are in quarantine,
you started fostering
a cat, right?
-Well, yeah.
Our lovely cat, Ollie,
of 16 years
died at the beginning
of lockdown.
And I thought, "We're not going
to get one now," right?
And Jane said,
"Well, let's foster them."
And I went, "What are you --"
"Well, it's better than
them being in a cage."
And I knew it wouldn't end well.
So we got this beautiful cat,
being fostered,
a rescue cat, you know,
to find it a home,
and it was sort of shy.
Within one day, it got on my lap
and looked at me,
and I went, "We're keeping it."
You know?
I was never going to --
How can I give it away now?
No.
-What did you name the cat?
-Pickle.
-[ Laughs ]
Pickle is a great name.
-Should I go and get her?
Should I try to find her?
-Yeah,
I would love to see Pickle.
Yes!
-She might struggle.
This might be --
She might knock the lights over.
Let's have a -- Hold on.
-This is very exciting.
-Wanna be on "Jimmy Fallon"?
He is not a moon-faced,
talentless hack.
He's a very good...
-Moon-faced, talented --
Oh, wow!
Pickle, hi.
Pickle, did you -- Oh, no, stop.
This is honestly the cutest.
Oh, did she say something?
Oh, stop it. Now look at --
Oh, Ricky, this is --
Oh, I'm taken, as well.
Everyone loves Pickle now.
Come on.
Thank you. Hi, Pickle.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Thank you for coming on.
-I won't stress her.
I'll let her go. Go on.
-Oh, my gosh.
You know, I wanted --
-I showed Jimmy Fallon
my pickle.
That's...
-Get in line, buddy.
Hey, you're doing something fun
during quarantine on Twitter
and Instagram, where, in part,
you answer questions
from people.
-Yeah, I just do this
a couple of times a week.
I do this sort of thing live.
I'm just here,
just talking to the people,
and they're sending
me questions.
And, you know, it's great.
It's really great, because I
think it's the closest you get,
you know, to connect,
'cause, you know,
you're actually talking to them,
and they tune in,
you know, every time.
It's great.
-What do they say so you?
-I sort of did it
'cause I thought,
"I should do something."
But, actually, I like it.
I like doing it now.
I really like the -- you know,
the feeling of this little club.
So it's great.
And they send me questions
that range from
philosophical questions
about the universe
and life and death and all that
to stupid ones,
like, you know,
"What if you had to swap
your mouth with your anus?"
-Wow. That's --
I'm going to just cross
that question off,
'cause I was going to ask --
I think I said, "I wouldn't
go to restaurants."
-That was the next question.
[ Both laugh ]
-But it's nice, as well,
'cause there's lots of, like,
cats and dogs on Twitter,
and I love it
when they ask me a question
from their perspective.
Like, one dog asked me,
"You've got a lot of awards,
but have you ever found
a really good stick?"
And stuff like that.
-Yeah, let's get down to
the brass tacks.
Have you ever had
a really good stick, man?
Come on. That's awesome.
-Have you ever stuck your head
out of a car window
when it's going really fast?
-That's living it up, man.
Ricky, I want to talk about your
television series, "After Life."
Man, I love this show.
Second season.
You're great in it.
I was saying earlier, you know,
it's a very funny show,
but it's also heartbreaking and
dealing with loss and grief.
And I love the balance
that you do there,
but I think only you can do it.
The two seasons are
on Netflix now,
so if anyone hasn't seen it,
they should check it out.
But, I mean,
you're getting a little --
a kind of pre-awards buzz
for Season 2,
so congrats on that.
I heard there's going to be
a Season 3 on the show.
What can you tell us?
Are you writing it?
-I've sort of written it,
you know?
I had more time this year
than I thought I'd have.
So, I wasn't sure about it.
You know, I knew Netflix wanted
a third season,
but, you know, they would
because, you know, the first two
were successful,
but I wanted to make sure it
wasn't an unwanted encore.
So I said, "We'll see."
And after about a week
when the Season 2 came out,
they called and said,
"Listen, let's do a third."
-I was going to show a clip of
"After Life" from Season 2,
but this is fun.
Right before we started
the show,
you said,
"Let me just send you this."
It's an outtake from Season 2.
And I love that you sent this.
Tell us what
we're going to see here.
It's very, very funny.
-Well, as you know, my leading
lady is a German shepherd.
And it's just fun all the time.
We do the take,
and then things happen.
And I don't know why
she did this,
but it was after a take.
This dog suddenly decided
to show how much she loved me.
-Let's take a look at this.
Here's Ricky Gervais
and his co-star.
-Good girl.
Alright, that's enough. Right.
Okay. Okay.
Yeah, I'm going to
have a shower.
Cheers. Down.
Bad girl, Brandy. Bad girl.
Bad girl, Brandy.
[ Laughs ]
-Almost.
-Thank you.
It's like,
for the first couple of seconds,
I tried to stay in character.
I sort of laughed and said,
Brandy, like, her stage name,
and then I thought,
"We can't use this."
It looks mental."
Oh!
But I should say, to be fair,
all the actors do that to me
after a take.
They love me so much.
-Ah! See?
That right there deserves
an award right there.
That scene right there
is what I love.
I love that she finished.
She goes -- Finally like a
couple more licks.
"Alright, I'm done."
And perfect timing --
you go, "Thank you."
It's so good.
Ricky Gervais, the first
two seasons of "After Life"
are on Netflix now.